thank you guys your perspectives have
changed my mind in many ways so do you
think life will ever go back to what we
knew or should I start to adopt a new
normal as much as I hate that term hmm
yeah the old normal is done I think we
know that for sure
yeah it's impossible to imagine we go
back even if things formerly went back
to allowing you to interact the way you
once did I think we're all a bit rattled
at what we've now seen we've seen we've
seen a threat to our way of life and
this is true no matter who you are no
matter which side of this divide you're
on we've seen a threat to our way of
life we have seen people open up
possibilities that we didn't realize
were near at hand and we've also seen
that things can sneak up on us Kove at
19 I increasingly believe is a
self-inflicted wound but to the extent
that a self-inflicted wound can emerge
from someplace half a world away and you
know bring us to our knees we should
have been preparing for that all along
it wasn't a secret that it could happen
and the fact that we didn't and the fact
that it's done this to us and the fact
that it may have unleashed the social
unrest all of these are evidence of what
it is that we're not paying attention to
during so-called normal times so in some
ways normal is over and that's probably
a good thing
[Music]